hey youtubers it's Charlie so good news
it seems like the Justice League and
Suicide Squad characters that the TV
shows have lost can totally come back so
we got a little clarification here's
just a breakdown of what's going on you
know between TV show movie characters
there were a lot of conventions over the
weekend so naturally a lot of TV actors
were appearing in various places Stephen
Amell did a panel where he says
something really interesting about TV
versus movie characters just because
there's always a big question with what
are the TV shows allowed to do does the
character appearing in the movies like
say Deathstroke mean that he can never
appear on the TV shows again so while I
think it's important to understand that
this changes on a daily basis he did say
Deathstroke specifically was not
off-limits to them on the TV show so if
Manu Bennett became available in they
had room in their schedule they totally
bring him back like he said his dream
team arrow would have Deathstroke and
Huntress on it that could totally happen
in a future season but he just said a
long time ago Diane Nelson who's kind of
in charge of all Warner Brothers DC
things along with Geoff Johns now Geoff
Johns has been up now to be in charge of
DC films but it used to just be Diane
Nelson he said that she sent him like a
very nice letter explaining their thesis
for why the movies should be different
from the TV shows like why the party
line is different from Marvel's
everything is connected and it was
mostly in favor of allowing the TV shows
to do their own thing while the movies
did their own thing and they they didn't
have to worry about stepping on each
other's toes now that doesn't
automatically mean that the TV shows can
do whatever they want to do I definitely
think there have been cases in the past
where they've been asked to diminish the
role of certain properties that are
moving into the movies like last year
there was the offhanded remark that
Willa Holland who plays Thea made about
the Suicide Squad on arrow how they were
forced to kill them off because they
were going to become this big thing in
the movies as they were ramping up to
make the Suicide Squad film now that may
or may not be true I do think that they
have a lot of choice in the characters
that they do even if there are movie
characters happening so like they could
probably do some of the Suicide Squad
characters but when the producers say oh
you know it's our choice to not do
characters you do kind of wonder if
they're being pre-emptive like if you
know somebody's going to take something
away from you maybe you put it in the
we been before they have the opportunity
to come take it away from you so it
doesn't become a big thing behind the
scenes like everybody just trying to be
nice with each other
so it all sounds really confusing and
political I think it's less of a big
deal now I think they're a little bit
more open
we have Superman coming onto the TV
shows they probably have to make a
pretty strong case for big characters
like that like explain to us you know us
at Warner Brothers why you need this
huge character that we're doing in the
movies right now like why will this help
your TV show so keep in mind that
anytime actors make comments about being
able to do characters from the movies or
not being able to do characters in the
movies so you just need to take it with
a grain of salt because this changes
year to year I think it changes with the
success or failure of stuff that happens
in the movies like I think Superman
quote-unquote dying at the end of Batman
V Superman and kind of going away for
awhile and Justice League help Supergirl
get the character the real test of
Superman on the TV shows will be what
happens after Justice Lee comes out and
Superman Returns but if you're someone
who's been watching superhero TV shows
since before Smallville then you know
the ups and downs of those characters on
TV you know there was a Superman TV show
for a while it was called Smallville
they will be another Superman TV show
eventually but because that would
probably undercut supergirls character I
think they'll wait till after Supergirl
ends its run but you know safe bet 7
seasons for most TV shows and yeah I
totally think that Batman will
eventually show up on the TV shows now
there might not be another Batman TV
show for a long long time at least not a
live-action show but that doesn't mean
that he won't appear in other people's
TV shows eventually I think the real
trick of the TV shows now the Berlanti
versus a good example is doing big
secret Wars crisis on Infinite Earths
style crossovers in finding a way to do
a comic book universe on TV not just
like a standalone procedural TV show
like a CSI comic book show so that's the
real challenge if they can pull that off
I think they'll have a much better shot
of getting characters like Batman
because it's like oh my God look at this
giant universe of course Batman exists
here but say like Lucifer on Fox like
you know it's a DC comic book property
so yeah Bruce Wayne is like somewhere in
there but there
much less of a reason to have him on if
it's not this big wide universe if it's
a really self-contained show and it has
decent ratings there's really no
incentive to bring Batman on but if
you're gonna do a giant crisis on
Infinite Earths story with like four or
five six TV shows all at once then yeah
that would be an occasion to bring
Batman on the screen but big takeaway is
is that Deathstroke is not gone from
arrow Suicide Squad not gone from arrow
completely but I think the real trick is
is seeing what they do this year in how
they get back to some of that stuff
because it all comes full circle by the
end I'm expecting seven seasons from
arrow so I think we will get that
Deathstroke Huntress team arrow before
season 7 goes down but here's the real
question though when do you think that
we'll see Batman pop up or Bruce Wayne
get a name drop see his face on screen
in the Berlanti verse on any of the TV
shows flash arrow legends of tomorrow
Supergirl just a character who was
referenced by other characters as Bruce
Wayne or Batman I'm willing to give him
some wiggle room but I always felt like
endgame for arrow was Bruce Wayne
approaching Oliver to offer him
membership in the Justice League of the
TV universe like even if it's a
flash-forward you just see him standing
with Batman Superman the flash and
they're all doing that all for one one
for all as they put their hands together
and then it just like slams to black
like oh my god Justice League we're here
but after arrow does go off the air in a
couple years I'm gonna probably a couple
years I do want to see Stephen Amell
come back to guest star every once in a
while as Oliver in like a live-action
Young Justice show they'd be pretty
funny like let me know in the comments
if arrow goes off the air which it will
before some of the other DC TV shows how
would you want to see the other TV shows
you Stephen Amell as a guest star where
you guys think about that I'll say
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner Nightwing you win a $20 Amazon
gift card be sure to private message me
on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact details the DC giveaway
is still going on I'm expecting a
Supergirl Superman trailer pretties you
know maybe next week maybe the week
after that we're pretty much within like
the one month period of Supergirl
starting and that's really when they
start to drop footage so they'll be more
flash more arrow more legends of
tomorrow reverse flash so there'll be
much more trailers for all the superhero
shows not
just the DC stuff for all the Marvel
shows too especially Luke cage which is
premiering at the end of this month but
what's gonna happen later tonight is
I'll be posting a new thor ragnarok like
they just showed off some of the new
costumes that they're all wearing like
everybody gets an upgrade for thor
ragnarok as you would expect every time
there's a new movie everybody gets a
little upgrade while you guys wait for
that to post you can click here to learn
all about the flash movie and you can
click here to watch that Deathstroke
teaser again thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight